back in the day league of legends had 40
champions you could choose from nowadays
that number is more like 156
roughly four times what it used to be
obviously it's great to have so many
champions to choose from but sometimes
new champions bring a whole load of new
balancing issues
i hate playing against this [ __ ]
chair
and just before we get into this video
make sure you subscribe to the score
esports that way you'll never miss a
video just like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 broken league
of legends champions
coming in at our number 10 spot is a
champion that was so broken upon release
players could only describe the
experience of playing against her as
miserable gwen dealt percentage health
damage on autos and had a shroud that
moved when she moved and protected her
from all damage abilities oh yeah she
also has a dash gains damage based on
her health was untargetable had a 50
ability cooldown refund you get the
picture those facing her had 99 problems
and gwen was all of them
i want to try and clear this
oh okay
that champion is [ __ ] broken i don't
care what anybody says that is the most
ridiculous [ __ ] i've ever seen in life
thankfully riot realized rolling
multiple champions into one like this
didn't exactly make for fair balance
gameplay and after officially becoming
the most banned champion in platt and
above gwen was finally nerfed in july
2021
is there anything more annoying than
someone having a good time while making
your life miserable
[Music]
well zoe is exactly that kind of
obnoxious champion which is why she
takes the number nine spot on our list
on top of having rng the ability to one
shot you from long range and using your
own tools against you the trickster
champion also had a pretty toxic loud
mouth personality not so great to play
against but really fun to play with
the [ __ ] despite riot's half-hearted
attempts to reign her in zoe stayed
broken for a good long while before
finally receiving a massive nerf in
patch 8.16 but if we're being honest
here she's still kind of busted
at number eight now we have irelia a
champion that's made many league players
question their sanity she takes a little
skill a little
but she's so cancer to play against if
you don't play it like
cancel cancer as well
so disgusting the blade dancer used to
dominate any early game she was in and
1v1 by slashing through minion waves
like a hot knife through butter that is
before she received a number of
significant nerfs in patch 11.14
while there were a bunch of players
complaining about her being brain dead
and weak after the rework it doesn't
seem like that's actually the case and
irelia remains as broken as ever it
might take a couple of days for people
to get used to the changes okay
after that
champion is not balanced i guarantee you
and number seven pick viego was made to
suffer but more often than not he was
the one bringing the pain dude poe
this chip is not balanced guys yep yep
this champ is not balanced guys that is
the reset
i i don't think there's many people in
the game who think viego is balanced
maybe the designer thinks that he's
balanced they're like i think we did a
great job guys one of diego's coolest
abilities is possession he's able to
take over a dead player's body use a
percentage of their health to regen
himself and then use their items basic
attacks and abilities diego literally
punishes the enemy for doing well and it
doesn't even end there in the beginning
viego was a stealthy mannerless champion
with high base health he was able to
sustain his way through nearly all
stages of the game back with acadian
about to drop now contracts are going to
go in here for the reset and impact the
big man on campus he don't go to the
party he is the party and evil geniuses
get the ace alcohol dracto
let's go one he gets the kills here
cleaning up the ruin king was hit with
some heavy nerfs in patch 11.17
including a reduction to his auto attack
range as well as a few nerfs to his alt
heartbreaker with the hopes of bringing
his reign of terror to an end
coming in at number six we have league's
first assassin akali early on akali was
an easy champion to pilot and destroyed
lower elos but she wasn't seeing a whole
lot of action in pro play bryant's
solution was a massive 2018 rework that
turned icarly into an absolute beast
nin goes in finally gets one but
showmaker gets an instant reply now the
shy gets blown up by show maker who is
putting on a show rookie has no manner
and he holds on to the flash triple for
showmaker while ocarly was always a
flashy champion her having basically no
weaknesses and a bloated kit was pretty
problematic
i mean her kit is busted uh so just like
what i said about atrox it all comes
down to the numbers i think the q looks
overly busted the w looks overly busted
have to know exactly what the ratios are
for the the r and the e passive looks
nuts as well once again riot attempted
to balance icarly by nerfing some things
and buffing others over the course of
the next few years but to this day many
players claim the rogue assassin is
still
busted at number five now we have a
champion who can lane versus anyone and
anything it's darius the hand of noxus
has been around for a long time but he's
never been more busted than in 2015 with
the release of riot's juggernaut update
darius became a champion that could take
big hits and hit back even harder here's
the battle carson alone in front
absorbing gets dunked so as his online
he's still going he doesn't get the
third as the zonius comes across he gets
some damage on the stage
to save the game soaz gets a pentagon
after baron darius's alt bleed stacks
ability to deal damage to multiple
enemies with q and heal the longer he
fought made him a fearsome top lane
opponent after going through riot's
usual cycle of repeated buffs and nerfs
darius seems to be making a meta
comeback in season 11. so the rest of
the champions should probably get their
lunch money ready caps gets to the
backline as neon is forced away limit
trying to get away as well but reckless
is on the hunt and on the chase and the
shutdown comes out neon down jinx down
but here
the noxian guillotine
broken blade cutting through g2 as
quickly as he can as caps now it's all
on him to do it again
broken with the decimate heals himself
back up caps with the
kill for broken blade
our fourth pick for this list is rise
the champion who at one point could
basically machine gun you down with
spells on the hunt goes in that's gonna
be hodgin in a real sticky situation
he goes down a full three-man nar
ultimate that's gonna be smack down now
eyes onto the 80 carry but the support
hits it's gonna be kuro out safely pray
however has to run away from his base sk
telecom looking to take down the final
nexus turrets it does not look good for
kuro and his team coup tigers are
falling skt will be your first ever
two-time world champions of course if it
was just faker who did well with ryze
we'd need to ask some questions but he
was pretty op in other players hands too
if they get two people on him vayne can
chunk him down pretty quick
just can't get caught oh yeah
block right now for piglet this is
actually nice positioning
can they do it piglet very close to take
it on hanson pushes him up against the
wall there's the saris embrace along
with the arcane mastery coming out oh
he goes down to hauntzer and that means
piglet has to run for his life the
desperate powers out he locks him up he
comes up with a double kill and the turn
the top side is destroyed gravity's got
the game inevitably rise was nerfed his
q's passive shield and his damage were
lowered the spellflux cooldown was
increased and his roots were made
shorter it's not that he's unplayable or
anything it's just that 2015 world era
ride was as broken as it gets and not
gonna lie here we're all kind of waiting
for a comeback stat with the two dragon
averages rockets usually want to take
one a lot later in fnatic well they're
the ones who couldn't contest this time
around meanwhile though steve is getting
chunked out by huni who's finally gotten
rolling and he's stunned up after the
flash hoonie follows him through and
solos him down
league's alpha release and number three
pick twisted fate was incredibly broken
so much so that the champion saw a 100
ban rate in competitive play during
those early seasons red cards during
team fights can be directly traced to
entire game losses in fact this
iteration of twisted fate has been
called the most broken champion league
has ever seen he basically had double
damage on his auto attacks could
teleport globally with a three second
cooldown and had an alt that gave him
global vision by closed beta and beyond
twisted fate underwent a number of
changes aimed at making him a bit less
of an overpowered nightmare and these
days in the right hands tf can still
wreak some serious havoc
that's a pick
sitting at number two is a champion who
define what it meant to be broken upon
release every busted champion that came
after xin zhao is inevitably xin zhao
2.0 his base attack speed was high and
his base damage was monstrous xin zhao
could easily take on a 1v5 and win to
give you an idea of just how insanely
overpowered he was xin zhao has had the
honor of being the first champion to be
hotfix within a couple of weeks of being
released anyone who had to truly
experience old xinjiao will understand
the amount of stress and frustration
that came with playing against him
once he reached level 6 it was game over
for everyone in the vicinity and he
could just 1v5 with ease and was so
overpowered that the only true counter
was to just build four mail on everyone
i'm sure you can guess where i'm going
with all of this like all of riot's
releases especially ones that go as far
back as the earliest versions of league
xinjiang went through a ton of changes
throughout the years nowadays riot
admits that xin zhao struggles with his
early game and scaling and it'll
probably take a lot to bring him back
but it's unlikely that his glorious
debut will ever be forgotten
and that brings us to our top pick the
champion that really needs no
introduction still but he might
affiliate
how many years
as he just lights up everyone and gets
the baron as one of league's most unique
champions a felios was also busted in
very unique ways his kit was unlike
anything riot had created before
aphelios could switch between five
different guns with different abilities
and each one of those guns also gave him
a different alt depending on which one
the champion was using
oh my god
what the [ __ ] but putting aside his
ability to basically one one-shot entire
teams with one of those alts athalios
wielded the most formidable weapon of
all confusion and he shot vista oh yeah
with his cue marked him up there's the
ultimate gonna land a few extras and
that's what happens with calibration
explain to me what just happened he
mocked them and then because they're
marked for some reason you can hit them
across the other side of the map i don't
know i didn't code this champion but
he's busted all right it's silly why can
you do that despite a hotfix release
just a few days after his release he
continued to sow chaos for another year
and didn't approach anything close to
balance that is until he went through
nine consecutive rounds of nerfs that's
nine and while a felios remains one of
riot's coolest champions to date he is
also in our opinion they're most broken
well those were our most broken
champions in league of legends did we
miss out any good ones any really busted
champions that should have been in the
video let us know and also let us know
what video you want to see next on the
channel thanks for watching and i'll see
you all in the next one
[Music]
oh man
oh my god oh my god
what the [ __ ]